hey what someone else emulates and if
you would like to come and work in part
of the Samuel eaves team as part of the
family we are looking for videographers
marketers we're looking for property
training advisors we're looking for
customer service advisors we're looking
for sales to build a sales team we're
looking for accountants we're looking
for finance directors we've literally
remove it too longer and we are
expanding massively with ten times the
growth of our business and we are going
to be recruiting like crazy in London so
what kind of people are looking for
we're looking for positive high-energy
people that want to grow and develop
into a career where the mission is to
help and change the lives of other
people to make a massive impact it's not
going to five it's start-to-finish
we work hard we play hard we're generous
with our wages and we're looking to
recruit good people so if you are
interested in working as part of a team
in central London
we're at like mirrolure bone area near
Baker Street in London Centre so if
you'd like to come and have an interview
for working with the company then please
fill out the link below and get yourself
down to London real soon Russell the CEO
are you excited Ross what kind of people
are we looking for what what is an
intranet what is that but they want to
be someone that has the freedom to think
outside the box and the freedom to do
what they think and take the business
forward in their own way so the only
people that could come oh yeah we don't
want to give you a job we want to give
you a mission in the career right so you
can think like a business person but
bring your skills to the table and help
me polish something big and gray which
is what we're doing well I think we're
the best property investment training
company on the planet
and I'd love you to be part of that so
fill out your details and commence
offices have a chat